Okay, here we go.
So welcome to you all welcome to Session 9. This
is the last session of modules two and
three.
and
this is the last session before we get into neural networks on
Monday.
in this session, our focus is going to be
singular value decomposition
Which according to one book?
Some mathematicians call the jewel.
of the linear algebra So today we're going to
employ all of the well
a lot of the linear algebra technique we've seen so far to
perform this decomposition of a matrix.
Let me write down the agenda.
So today is the 16th. Yes of July 2022.
before I continue
the assignments
for more there will be to us because we have two modules two and
three there will be two assignments for each module. These will
be posted on Monday.
And they will be due.
At the end of the third month the fourth module.
And for the fourth module the assignment
will be due at the end of that module.
If I pull up my calendar.
Assignments two and three will be due.
on Monday
at 25th
So the at the end of fourth module.
and for module 4
It will be.
the first of August
Okay.
so you will have time to work on both these just
If you asked like you'll be notified.
Okay.
Now, what are we doing today? Today? We are going to
Put all our attention to SVD.
so I'm going to
start with a formulation for SVD.
And then we're going to look at a full example.
of singular value decompetition
of some Matrix
first we will do this with math.
You know, like I always do in markdown.
And then we will turn to do this with python.
Well Done by to be specific now numpy
has a
method called SVD
But before without just before we do that, we
want to see how the SVD method works. So
we will look at the implementation of
SVD without using that method so
You know not by has some other built-in methods that we will use.
To replicate what the SVD method doesn't buy.
Because we want to understand how it works before we just use it.
out of the box
I also want us to do an exercise on SVD. We
haven't really had the
time to do exercises in the few
past few sessions because of just how much
the content there is to cover.
but we should be able to do this after we've covered items
to items wanted to
and then I want to show you an application.
of SVD
so
for PCA
if we have time we can also talk about as PC but
next week.
Or we start our session on new networks. We've
also talk about PCA because what
we're going to do is work on we will
import a data set. I'll give you data set that you will import into
your jupyter notebook.
And then we will construct a neural network.
that will
learn
the
we call them the weights or the parameters of the data.
See if you have the data you learn the parameters you can
then make predictions.
For future data, if you remember I give
you the example of Real Estate.
So for example to show the machine learning model
700 properties.
And they will learn the parameters the significance.
of
The factors that would cause a property
to be expensive or not expensive.
And once it has learned the parameters what once
it has learned a pattern.
The next time we will present to it a property it will be able
to estimate.
Okay, and we want to build the
model in such a way that the prediction is also very accurate. Remember?
on our session on
Wednesday we said that there are four forecasting a
price.
For this particular example, there are two metrics that
we want to look at errors, which you want to converge to
0.
And something called r squared what you wanted to converge to 1.
so
that's the kind of model. We want to create a model that will have
a very small error close to zero and a high
r squared.
That will be the first instance in the next instance. We will
look at a data that's going to be very large.
And for that large that we will use PCA and I'll give
you one example for finance.
For SVD if we don't if I don't manage to
do it.
Today because there are still something about techniques
we haven't talked about. So if I don't manage to do that today, I
will give you a notebook.
for
image compression
if you remember the slides, I I mentioned at least three applications
of
PCA which is a special type of SVD.
Specific case of SVD and that was computer vision
image compression falls on the computer version.
there was dimensional reduction and there was
stock protection. So we're going to look at all three of these examples.
Next week not a decision. So this
these two modules out we've gone
through was all about the mathematics.
Of these techniques and of course,
we also looked at pythonoplepitations, but
actually it's going to be all.
It's gonna be primarily python next week. So tensorflow
numpy.
pandas
we might use psychic learn but for
The statistical Parts. But anyway, we'll
talk about people talk about that on Monday.
What was number five?
Yes, and we make a reference to PCA.
Okay time allows it. Very good.
So I'm going to create a new markdown file.
Which you will call 15.
so math tutorial 15
or singular value decomposition
I'm going to zoom out so you can see everything on the right panically.
and we're gonna have to put on my glasses because
I want this too small, but and we
need I need the space here.
All right.
now
the example I'm going to give you.
Is based on?
at least
three books because I could not
find one book though clearly explain SVD
with all of the techniques required
I'll give you the references of course, but let's begin with
a simple two by two Matrix.
And the simple two by two Matrix is this one?
This is one of the books that are that I'll
be referencing. This is It's called.
linear algebra for the 21st century
If you can see it anyway, the references will be in the file.
I'll share with you and SVD is a major component.
Like it's a central piece of this book.
But the book doesn't go into the prerequisite enough.
So you cannot learn from this book anyway.
You can look at this book later on after this Workshop. So let's
say we have this Matrix.
a simple two by two Matrix
we have a and then we also pull up my notes so
we can I can copy paste.
latex
Very quickly.
We have a
2 by 2 Matrix
which we will call a
and
let me construct The Matrix.
Here we go.
This will be equal to 10 to 5
11.
10 2
now
to decompose this Matrix is to create
three matrices that look like so
so a
will be factored into three matrices.
There will be a
there will be
us and V
you snv
so we have you.
times s
times V which is transposed
What are these matrices?
you
Is an M by m?
Diagonal matrix orthogonal Matrix now I
will need to clarify what orthogonalism
north orthonormalists towards uniform
my last session.
When I looked up of the normal on Google.
the first
couple of search results said that they are
synonymous.
I suspected they were not but I
mmm changed my change my agenda here.
To make it as if they're the same they are not the same.
okay, there's a reason why they have different names, so I'm
going to
In a moment go over orthogonal Matrix
and then tell you how it's distinct from
Ocean normal Matrix.
I said in the past, you know not
to use Google for technical reference.
and once again
You know, I found that what was online is incorrect.
So I shouldn't have checked that anyway, so you is
a is an orthogonal Matrix.
Now this book called the orthogonal.
but
you see the problem is some mathematical literature use
orthogonal and orthonormal synonymously or
as they're not the same thing. So I'm going to call this.
If I remember collected correctly, this should be
an orthonormal.
normal, okay, but
This is called orthogonal because I don't want to.
Make any mistakes here. This would be consistent
and then
if it turns out to be orthograph of the normal and this example,
I will change it here.
Then we have S.
S is a matrix containing is a
diagonal matrix.
Is a diagonal matrix?
containing singular values
the singular values of
a
matrix which is not denoted here.
We will see that in a minute.
And the diagonal matrix containing or of the singular
values.
By singular values, we mean the eigenvalues.
And then the V Matrix or V transpose?
Is also an orthogonal Matrix or I should
say V here?
V transpose is also an orthogonal Matrix.
The first one is actually M and by m
and the other one is n by n
and a itself
Is an Empire is an M by n Matrix, so
it doesn't have to be square in this example a is a square
Matrix, but you can perform SVD on Rick on
any rectangular Matrix.
is
and then buy it.
Matrix
Okay.
So I would be the number of rows and would be the number of columns.
We want to see how we can decompose this now to
decompose this if we have a free perform SVD
on this Matrix.
We would get.
u s v
Which will be equal to?
the following
so you would be let me copy this
snippet.
Three over five I'll use decimal notation.
So three or five is 0.6.
This would be
negative 0.8
0.8 and zero point
six
That's the Matrix U.
Then we have the Matrix S which will contain
the singular values or eigenvalues?
So this is 10 times.
The square root of 2 what is 10 times square the
square root of 2?
10 times the square root of
2 so that's 2 to the power.
0.5 14
okay, I'm just going to
on the up to the two decimal places
then we have zero and then zero.
And then five times the power square root
of 2.
so 5 times
the square root of 2
So 7 7.077 point?
zero seven
That's the Matrix S. So these are the singular values.
Okay.
Now we'll talk about why this particular metric
is so important.
And then we have V transpose, which is in this case.
One over the square root of two.
so one over
two to the power
0.70
for all of that
This one is negative.
Has anyone looked up SVD before
this session?
If you've already had a look at it, if you try to read about
it beforehand just talked a little while in the chat. Why
for? Yes, otherwise type in Inferno.
How about you rest in Cuba?
Have you looked at look into SPD before this session?
Yes or no?
Okay, no response.
the name of the book the name of the book see if
I pull up the
the references
these are the books.
Rancis is in theory. Okay. So these are
the books that I've referenced.
so this one that we're talking about is
actually
eight
I need to see which page it is exactly, but it's
chapter 7.
But not exactly because I am not just a copy
pasting the material. I'm
adding more comments. I'm expanding on it. So this is
actually two things. It's a book number eight.
Which is the one from Strang?
and
the other one which is
which is that which is a program copying this example AJ Roberts.
a
Dr. Roberts
Leaning algebra for the 21st century linear algebra.
And these dot dots I put here because I need to properly format the
references.
Include, you know to include a public publisher name
and addition number.
Number six I think was an online Source. That's why I haven't tapped it.
But you'll have access to all of these.
the thing is you cannot learn from one book only you need to
you might see one term or one Concept in one book, but it
doesn't go into details. I have to look into another book.
This one was very important the third one.
This is a
very intuitive approach to teaching linear
algebra. So if you want a good foundation.
In linear algebra, I highly recommend you getting this book.
Hey, we just search those terms. You will find it on Amazon.
Okay, let's return here.
So this is based on a book number eight and book
number nine.
Which is on page?
okay.
So let me break down the steps for you.
How we can go from this?
To that. There's quite
a bit of work involved here.
But then once we understand the steps, we can
apply these steps to any.
Matrix
and then we could
Do image compression we could extract?
You know, if you remember we talked about PC that
the principal components.
for dimensional reduction, so
all of the applications of SVD would be
available to us
let me show you one example just to keep just make it interesting
before we jump into the
the work of it decomposing. I'm gonna type
an SVD image.
compression
Just let me show you the images. So there is
something called a rank of a matrix and I'll show you how to.
a rank of Matrix
but you can
compress an image
to compress an image means to retain the important qualities of
a picture.
And discard the qualities that are rest relevant so that
you can reduce the size of the file without losing
the entropy entropy means the
quality or the the value of
the message.
Now with an SVD algorithm which will I'll show
you in one I will show you SVD adapted for image
compression you can choose the rank the higher the
rank the closer the
compressed images to the original
let's take another example.
Let's say this one.
Where is
that picture?
It's not clear enough.
I think you already get the idea but let's here's another
example right you have an image.
That is 40k.
Now you can compress it. Now. This is not a high
quality compression, but you can increase or
decrease the rank. You can choose to keep more or
less of the singular values.
and
You know, I can adjust it accordingly. So if you want.
very high compression
So if you have a picture that doesn't have that has
a lot of contrast and not much gradient.
And there are the outlines are very clear. You can
use very high compression so you can significantly reduce
image size.
In cases like this where you do have a lot of different Shades of Gray a lot
of gradient. You may need a more.
A higher ranked compressed Matrix. Well, my
point is you can accomplish this so we can actually compress images and
retain much of the value.
One example where this
is is relevant isn't computer vision.
If you want to training machine learning model to detect.
footage
or detect the contents in
a computer in a picture or a video.
Well a video is a sequence of pictures.
If the video side is very large then.
It will take a long time for the model to predict.
What's going on that picture whereas if you compress the image?
The data is a lot smaller. And that means
the model will be a lot quicker to detect what's inside the picture.
So it has applications in storage.
It also has a applications and live prediction
like in the case of autonomous car.
Autonomous vehicles need to are getting
fed data from the cameras and they need to make decisions quickly.
So
this is what example where it might be very helpful.
All right.
But let's see how this is done. Let's look at the mathematics and we
will return to the application.
So step one. Let me first write down the steps and
then we'll perform the mathematics.
and for this I will return to
Gilbert strang's book
Now this is chapter 7.
and specifically page
So step one.
For step one we need to take the product.
of a and its transpose
so product
of
a and its transpose
so that's a times.
transpose of a times a
transpose of a
and then we do this again.
for a times the trans the transpose of a
Why do you do this? Because once we have these two matrices
who will then be able to extract the eigenvalues, but
when we do extract the eigenvalues?
We need to take the square root. So step three.
We want to calculate.
The eigenvalues if you like the single the singular values singular.
values for
steps one and two
four steps one and to order matrices
we generate in steps 1 and 2.
Once you have those singular values, we need to take the
square root of those angular of those singular values.
Okay, so calculate square root.
of singular values
once we have done this we have then we will have then created
the
Matrix S
And what about Matrix?
You and V transpose.
to calculate or Define this Matrix we
need to
orthogonalize
this Matrix
and then orthogonalize that Matrix.
or the transpose
so this we will orthogonalize it and what is
orthogonalized real content one in a moment?
We need to orthogonize orthogonalize this to get
that Matrix.
And then orthogonize this Matrix to get that
Matrix.
Now there are different algorithms for orthogonalization.
Okay, I'll tell you I'll describe to you the
problems of an orthogonal and orthonormal Matrix.
But there are different algorithms for orthogonalizing making
whatever this Matrix is.
The one we're going to look at is going to is called a
gram Schmidt.
algorithm
which is also supported by numpy and
even
well, not that algorithm specifically, I think the ones
numpy and Matlab support are
called a QR but these are both similar.
In what they do.
They both produce.
an orthogonal Matrix
now before let me just write down the steps.
and once we get to that step we will
We'll talk about orthogonal matrices. So step
5.
We will also.
Gonna lies make sure
God is very much thought. Oh, no.
nice
Matrix
in Step One
orthoglas The Matrix and step one
well, let me just
write down.
the product
so you'll orthogonalize this.
And we'll do the same four step number six.
Now these steps are not written anywhere. I am basically going over
the book here.
This is the book.
So I'm breaking down the steps by looking at the steps here.
Okay. I'm trying to simplify for you.
We're not doing this Matrix. We're doing the one here.
This we can do as an exercise.
Let me come back here.
then once we have done this
Yeah, we would have been we have we would have had a produced SVD.
Okay.
What we haven't covered yet is orthogonalization.
And some terms associated
with this technique like the rank of a matrix.
But let's talk about that once we get to step step 5
and 6.
so the product of ATA
that's where you multiply
This Matrix Ms. Transpose. You remember
what a transposes a transpose is. When where The
Columns of The Matrix?
Become the rows of the Matrix. So here
a if we were if I were to copy this.
That would give us the original Matrix we have up here.
times
The same Matrix but it's rows and columns have been swapped.
So this will be 10 5.
And then two 11 so 10 5.
and 2
okay.
Now to multiply these out.
I'm actually going to use numpy because I don't want to.
Do this by hand?
So I will come to.
I'll go to colab.
I will create.
a new notebook
SVD
or actually Pi 2 pi tutorial.
15 for SVD
I'm going to bring a numpy.
as NP
and so we have a
over the elements in this Matrix we have
10 2 5 11
so I'm going to print a and I'm going to print a
DOT T. If you want to transpose The
Matrix use the T attribute from numpy.
So let me run this.
And let me run that.
Okay.
So just like we saw in.
vs code
Now I'm going to multiply this. I'm going to go NP dot matte multiply.
and I am going to get
a DOT t and a
which will give us the Matrix.
One two five seven. Okay, this one exactly. So we'll get
a third Matrix.
one to five 75 1 2
and that may copy the copy paste this because this double
it's very similar for Step 2 for step
two it will be
Well the same thing but the order will be reversed.
So
The Matrix on the Right comes here
Okay, it's actually this one that needs to be reversed. It's
this one that needs to be reversed. So I'm going to
reverse
the order so
that
Okay, because it's transpose multiplied by the original
and this is the original.
Multiplier about the transports. Let me change that here.
like so
okay.
That's a time is transpose.
Up here to transpose.
times a
and here I just need to reverse the order.
I'm going to get this Matrix. So one of four one four
six.
so
one or four
one four six
72 72
Okay.
So I see this these two steps are are missing from this.
this formulation
Okay.
Now we need to calculate the singular values and
that's just eigen.
If you remember how we find the eigenvalues of
The Matrix.
First we use the determinant function.
Then we get the characteristic polynomial. Let me pull up
the previous tutorials just to refresh your memory.
Okay. So for step three, there's a sequence of
steps where we're just gonna since we've already looked at that we're gonna skip right
to the value, but let me refresh your memory.
Number 13 was it?
Yeah.
Here's how you calculate the eigen values of
Matrix. So let's say this is our Matrix.
We take the identity Matrix.
You know, that's just one across diagonal multiplied by
Lambda. This is just this is
the
the thing that is meant to be determined.
This is the indeterminate and we want to determine what the values
of Lambda are. So we multiply the scalar value by this identity
Matrix we get lambdo.
across the angle
Then we take the difference of Matrix a
minus this new Matrix.
And I give this characteristic polynomial and
then we solve for Lambda we get two roots.
We plug in these roots inside the eigenvector.
Or the values or excuse me, what we
do is we plug in we we put axis for our eigenvector.
And then we solve for the roots.
And these would be and these will be the values for our eigen
back here.
Okay.
Just double checking make sure I did not leave any steps in
this example.
Yeah.
Yeah, so this Matrix.
Is that Matrix after we plug
in one of these eigenvalues?
So for this Matrix, we chose one so you
plug in one inside the as we plug in
one for Lambda.
And this Matrix will be changed that Matrix.
So we'll get the eigenvector.
When we solve this system.
Okay, so I'm going to skip this whole step.
And just give you the the the eigenvalues.
for
these two matrices
it transpose times a
a times a transpose the eigenvalues for
these two.
All right.
so
I am going to return.
two
collab, this is Step. Number one.
This is the number one.
step number two was this
Okay.
step number three
the eigenvalues
so I'm going to denote this as
a t a
and this one aat
run that again.
this
Now if you want to calculate the eigenvalues there is
an attribute or I should say object in numpy called
linear algebra. So I'm going to go NP the
linear algebra and I valves
I can values.
So let's extract the eigenvalues for the first Matrix.
This will give us 50 and 200.
I do the same for the other one.
Yeah, so step three is eigenvalues for both matrices. I'm
going to print.
this one
and I'm going to print this one.
And so the eigenvalues are 50 and 200.
But what we do is we take the square roots of
these.
So the square root of 200.
The square root of 200 is what 200?
times out the powers 0.5
It's 14.4.
Just like we have here.
14.4
And the square root of 50.
would be
7.07 Okay, so we've
we have found.
The Matrix
S
The Matrix contain the singular value so the
square root of these values are the singular value
Which I will denote a sigma so Sigma sub 1
will be.
Let's just the first one.
at zero
But then I need to take the square roots. I have to import the mat.
The math library is so important math.
And then I'm going to go math.
That sqrt.
And the same thing for Sigma.
I'm going to print these.
Sigma 1
Okay 14.
And this would be seven.
point seven
Okay.
so
we get this Matrix.
four step three
The 14th.
point 14
and 7.4. Was it
0.7?
So this is now the Matrix U. This is
now.
The Matrix you
well
this is actually step 4 right step three is just
Sigma 1 and sigma 2 so Sigma
1 we said was equal to 200.
Sigma
2 was equal to 50.
then
Or number four. We just take square root of those Sigma. So
let me just add another Matrix.
This will be the square root this qrt.
skew
Sigma 1
Sigma 2
now
How do we get?
you
and V transpose
so for that we need to talk about the
first of all the definition of an orthogonal Matrix the distinction
of orthogonal and also normal and then
we will switch and talk about the
The gram Schmidt algorithm one
of the algorithms with which you can.
Or talk in the lives.
Is it clear up this point what we have done you have any
questions before we proceed to step five and six?
if it's clear at this point type the letter c
And then otherwise, let me know if you have any questions.
No questions.
Okay, if you have any questions, I will see them in that chat.
but yes, let's talk about
orthogonalization
so
this is the
A tutorial from week one which I have updated.
Okay, when you go to the dashboard this will be updated. So
this is
A PDF or HTML file from week one,
which I have.
With whichever appended definitions for orthogonal Matrix.
So let's look at it.
an orthogonal Matrix
sometimes used
Sonata or sometimes synonymously called
orthonormal
is a matrix that is
whose vectors?
In the column space imagine you
have a matrix.
If you take the columns as vectors.
And you take the product? Excuse me?
the Dutch product
also known as the inner product.
So we take the dot product of two columns and that Matrix.
And their value and the value of this product becomes zero.
Then we say that The Columns of this Matrix
are pairwise orthogonal.
What does it mean for the dot product of two
vectors to be 0 does anybody know like if you were to
plot these two vectors?
And their product is zero. What would those
two vectors look like?
any answers
Precisely they would be perpendicular.
Just like we saw in that cosine similarity example you
would get this.
remember when we when we took the cosine
similarity of
all the time dog in the building
like they had nothing to do each other. They were completely or no.
No those two were not completely orthogonal.
That was that was something else but they were quite the angle
was quite big.
but anyway for two vectors to be
orthograph means that they have
well, they're perpendicular.
If this was cosine similar, this would be they have you know.
Little to nothing to do with each other.
That's
that's an orthogical matrix. It's column vectors. We
all be orthogonal to each other perpendicular.
now
in some literature if you see here in some literature
an orthogonal Matrix is a matrix to
which only the first condition applies.
So nartholog Matrix is only a matrix
whose color vectors are perpendicular.
an orthonormal Matrix
Is a matrix to which both conditions wanted to
apply what is conditioned to?
condition two says that the magnitude
of each column Vector is zero.
How do we calculate the magnitude we've seen this before in one
of the previous sessions?
You see if I can put up the relevant document.
magazine
Here we go.
It's actually this file I scroll up.
Oh, it's not here. Okay.
It's an another file.
Let me show you magnitude.
magnetude
magni
toot
It will be this file.
There we go.
This is the magnitude and you know
also it's known as a norm.
easier synonyms
Typically you want to use double the two vertical bars.
Sometimes you will see single bars,
but this is not good practice because single bars also
used for the absolute value.
Anyway, the week calculate the magnitude of
a vector is to take
its components. Let's say this is a vector v
over R4 so four dimensional vector.
You take all four of its components Square them.
And then add the add up
the sum and then take the square root of that. Sum.
If that becomes zero.
Or if it becomes one that then you have a unit vector.
essentially unit Vector is one who's
radius is 1
so
Here if I return to.
as other file
it's called orthonormal.
Because it's magnitude is zero.
and
there's a word called normalize.
normalize is a
normalization is where
the largest component in a vector is one
and the smallest component is in a vectors 0 this
is after normalization.
I'll show you how that's done in a moment.
Okay, but I just thought maybe you've heard of this word normalization
before.
so
if you return to our tutorial.
We now need to orthogonalize.
Ta so we need to make an orthogonal Matrix.
I think is this orthonormal orthogonal. I think
this one is actually this is actually orthonormal.
But I'll have to double check.
Because this book I don't think it makes a distinction.
Either way, there are this is there there are
a few algorithms with which we can orthogenize or even orthonormalize a
matrix this Matrix in particular.
And that is called a gram Schmidt.
Algorithm, so let me show you the gram Schmidt algorithm.
It will be faster if I show you a picture.
in Google Images
Yeah, this is good.
Let me add one thing before I return here.
or
matrices
we're talking about the dot product, right?
Where was the file for DOT product?
dot product
here
So this is the this is how you denote?
Where is it the dot product? This is
one way to do it.
Let's start here.
Another way to denoted is like so to use
the vertical brackets.
So either this one or
to do this
two if you see this notation.
that's the same thing as that that
both of these are
you know dot product.
You call it can call this dot product because of the dot
in here. You can call this inner product because well.
They're inside the brackets.
I come here you will see.
that
in in other examples they used.
the brackets
Anyway, let's see what's going on in here.
say you have
a basis
Do you remember we said well we said about basis. We said that our
basis is a matrix.
whose vectors are
Over the two conditions by they will it's actually revisit that
let's make sure we remember what a we're actually if I should
remember what a basis is.
Basis we said bases.
as two conditions
bases
As they may is a set.
first of all
So this is this is this is the basis. This is a set.
It has vectors V1 V2 VN.
All three vectors must span the Subspace. What's
the Subspace RN?
So let's say we talk about a three-dimensional space.
So we need three points. XYZ each Vector
must have x y z
You can have one that's two Dimension. Another
one. That's four dimensions. All three must be of the same Dimension that's
condition. Number one.
Condition number two. They must be independent. What
does it mean for two vectors to be in two vectors
to be independent?
It means that when you take the linear combination and the linear combination is this
so let's say you have two vectors.
And you have two scalars.
Multiply this scalar without Vector multiply that's going
to but I back here at the product. It would be equal to zero. We
saw this in another example. We saw this in the last session.
So that's what a base is this. Okay for now,
just imagine it's just a matrix.
If you would to put these three columns inside.
If we would take the components of these vectors inside angle brackets,
it will be a matrix. So for not consider this to be a matrix column
one column two column three.
How do we orthogonalize?
You define a new variable or new Vector
W sub 1?
And that is just identical to V sub 1.
with components or with points if you
like 110
Then you will use the first Vector W
sub 1 to create a new Vector W sub 2.
How do you create W sub 2?
You take Vector 2.
And subtract it from this ratio.
So you have the dot product of V2 and
the first vector
over the dot product
of the first Factor
I mean exactly as you see it here.
This will become the first Vector of
the new Matrix.
This will become the new Vector of the second Matrix.
this
the new Vector of the third Matrix
so you must multiply the scalar value.
by the components of this third vector
you do this multiplication if you want if you do
the scalar product.
It gives you.
so in
Total we will get.
Yes, we'll get a new Matrix.
So the original Matrix was 1 1 0 1 2
0 0 1 2 this new Matrix will be.
This will be its first column.
This will be its second column.
This will be it.
third column
Now this is orthogonalization actually.
So these are the vectors.
of The orthogonal Matrix
These are the vectors after it has
been normalized.
If we take the square root of 2 over 2, so that's 2
over.
You can see.
It is 0.7. What I'm trying
to say is none of these components.
this squared over to
any of these components are above one. So when
we normalize a vector
None of the points in that Vector exceed one.
There will be between 0 and 1.
if the notation is a little too overwhelming and it
kind of is
let me simplify by taking a huge back to call app.
Okay, so let's actually use this as
an example.
I will.
Have one ones. Okay. So the original one is 1
1 0 1 2 0 0 1 2. Yes.
So for step number.
Five and six orthogonalization. I'm going to create a new
notebook before we do step number five.
We create a new.
But I want everything to be the same file.
No.
I'll just call this tutorial 15 p
p y
or you know, what orthogonization could be tutorial number
16 so tutorial.
number 16
Once again, I will import numpy.
And math just in case.
So the Matrix that we see in this picture.
Is Basis Matrix? So I'm going to call this B?
and P dot array
of course, I'm using the NP array method so
I can.
Use numpy actually beats and
methods.
it's
a vectors are 1 1 0 1 2 0 1 1
0.
1 2 0
0 1 2
and after orthog orthogonalization
we will get
these three vectors
one two and three
so
I will call this now. Orthogonal matrices
are usually denoted with the uppercase letter q
What I'm just going to call this B.
orthogonal
so we have
one negative 1 over 2 1 over 2 and
so that's just negative 0.5.
0.5 and 0 and third
one.
If you multiply the scalar value by these components will
get zero zero two.
zero
zero two
to make it orthonormal. Let me run this first.
To make this orthod over you see here.
This component is two It Isn't So this Vector is
not normalized.
These could be normalized but
this is just by virtue of the operations, but
Let me show you how to normalize this.
Normalizes, we must divide we must
find a magnitude of each factor.
And then divide each component.
or we can divide in
In vectors of matrices we can multiply it by one over the
norm.
And let me show you what I mean.
so
I will have N Sub 1 and sub 2 and sub 3
for these for each row.
so
Norm one will be equal to
NP dot linear algebra dot
Norm of the first
Let's just say column. So let's imagine these are columns are
actually Rose. But let's imagine these are colors. I'm gonna go B.
that's the norm of the first Factor.
if I want to normalize it I'm going to go be
And then multiply our multiplied by 1 over.
the norm
like so
I'll give you the new Vector 0.7 0.70.
so if I return here to this picture
That's 0.7.
Another way to express square root of 2, by the way, in case you didn't
catch this another way to express square
root of 2.
in math
So if you have square root of 2.
down here
That's just two raised to the power.
0.5.
That's what I'm doing in.
the my laptop calculator
so the square root of 2 the square
root of 2.
2 over the
To the power 0.5 over 2
0.7.
That's what they're trying to say here. These have been normalized.
If you see here what we do is we take the first Vector divided
by its magnitude.
And that's exactly what we've done here.
here
normalized
so then
if we create a new Matrix.
We orthonormal.
then
the First Column and be orthonormal
would be
this vector
So let me run this.
I cannot leave this up to you. Okay?
I'm just going to put three zeros in here just as placeholders.
There's actually a method called zeros, but never mind that for now.
one vector
Okay.
So that's the first column.
of The orthonormal Matrix
I'll go ahead and do the same for
the others now just to simplify the code. I'm going to take this bit.
It's just remember.
This will normalize the first Factor.
And make that the First Column of the orthonormal effect
Matrix.
And I'm just going to copy paste this for the other matrices. This
would be one.
one
so
normalize
the vectors
of B
and
a vectors orthogonide be
after
also, go now lization
You can see this picture for reference.
see
Graham
Schmitt
Algorithm here.
And then if I print p orthonormal
try to reassign it now.
Okay.
I want to let me reassign I guess I could do this.
And then you start at this
repent. Let's try a pen.
So we'll append the first vector.
And then the second vector and then third vector.
once more
What does it push?
anybody know how to add a
element to an Empire array
P array
yeah, it's a pen.
Okay, maybe I should say.
Why is it complaining about attribute? I'm referring to a method. All
right, so it's saying NPA rate does not have a method.
All right.
I guess I'll just do it a different way. I'll go NP.
and P dot array
and I'll just create them all at this.
simultaneously
like so
there we go.
There we go. That's the that's the orthonormal Matrix
now.
You see not of it's components.
exceed zero or go below zero
If we were to plot these vectors, they
would be orthogonal and they would have they
would not exceed a radius of one.
This is what an orthonormal Matrix is.
Now, let me show you how to do this using.
Numpy without you know manually doing this calculation.
so
I will return here.
To show you how to order the normalize.
ATA
Okay, so if you remember ATA.
Is that Matrix?
the orthogonalize it
there is a method called. Let me
see what it was called.
It's called Earth. So I'm gonna go.
NP Lin algebra
dot Force
this is orthonormalized I believe.
And I'm going to plug in.
Let's do 88 first.
So even the graphic the code I have is actually from side pie.
So I'm gonna let me import although numpy does
extend Psy pie. But anyway, sa pi,
Dot
I'm actually just leave it at that.
sci-fi linear algebra
or the normalize
why?
Okay. There we go.
So that's how you orthonalizing python.
That's the first that's so this is the Matrix. This is
the Matrix U, right? This is u,
I come back here.
That's the U Matrix.
Okay.
And then we have the V Matrix.
That's step number six.
V
So if we print U.
We print V.
So this one?
0.70
so we have the same Matrix up here.
and for s
for us we will we have up here. Right? We took we
have Sigma 1 and sigma 2
so for the Matrix as
That would be step.
Four step four we put into a
matrix. So step four.
We have a new Matrix called S and P dot
array.
which will be
let me just reorder these this will be Sigma.
want to
Be fine.
So we have Sigma 1 and
0.
That's the first.
vector
the other vector
is zero
Sigma 2
Okay.
SUV
There's s there is
you there is V.
If you put these three vectors together.
So I'm going to go NP. This is Step. This is
no not this we've already done steps six at
this point.
But I'm just gonna multiply all three vectors. I'm
going to go math multiplication now math multiple takes two arguments at
a time.
So I'm gonna first add multiply the first two vectors.
that's
You and us so I'm going to first multiply these together.
So I will be.
You and this.
And then this will give us a new
Matrix which I'll multiply with v.
so NP Dot
matrix multiplication
this new Matrix with v
Let me run these cells again.
And if I come back here.
You can see we return to the original Matrix
10 to 5 11.
10 2 5 11
and it's already well. We already went away from one
one minute away from
the end of the session
but
let me type this.
to get
the orthogonalized so the orthogonalized orthogonal
Matrix would be the Matrix.
This isn't correct. By the way, this is s
this is s
The Matrix U
is
The gram Schmidt algorithm applied to that.
And we would be the grammishment algorithm applied to this.
so you
will be the let me type in text.
Ram Schmidt
algorithm applied to
ATA
a
and V is the same thing, but
the other way around
okay times a transpose.
Let me double check that make sure I didn't get the orders wrong.
Yeah, I think this is the correct order.
But I'll double check it anyway, but any either way, I mean, that's
how you get these two matrices.
Okay, just keep in mind that you do not
apply the grams with algorithm through just a on its own you have
to multiply you have to apply this algorithm to
the product of these two matrices. This
is the distinction in SVD.
Now finally if I bring you back to numpy.
We could have done this whole thing.
using
the SVD algorithm from numpy. So this would be SVD.
Let me call a manual for lack of better words.
but if you want to do this
There's a very nice method that does this whole thing in one go.
So I'm gonna have here SVD.
the SVD method from the pi
So this will be what NP? I think
Lin algebra.
dot SVD our plus an A
and this method will return
What did you turn values?
Three vectors USV in that
order, so I'm going to go.
you
s
V
If I print them all print you.
Let's try to be.
You see we have to say matrices.
This is V.
Like we have up here.
This is the this is the eigenvector. But what
you would do is you would take the values.
And put them in a square Matrix.
And of course, that's Matrix U.
Of course if you want to multiply these together.
So if it works it perform this operation down here.
Oh, yeah, because this is not as I need
to fix. So yes see because we can't just multiply this vector.
We need us to be a matrix. So we need
us to be a matrix.
Anyways, that's Matrix up here. It's exactly this one up here.
this is really redundant but
What I'm saying is you'll get them say Matrix back.
now
Let me put this in here again because this is the this is
this I think this was very good.
very concise clear
Example of how use gram Schmidt so I'm going to copy this and
I will include it here inside.
this file
gram Schmidt
See grab Schmidt.
Okay.
I will write this down. Anyway, I will create a
markdown file.
hopefully, you know you remember I mean
as long as you know, what I got product is and what the
the norm or magnitude of a vector is
well, then, you know, this should completely make sense to you.
And the only thing special about SVD is that we don't just take the
we don't just apply grammishment to the origin
Matrix, but
Matrix a times it's transpose.
That's u and v
Any questions before I wrap up?
But let me let me all say this while you think about your question.
Now that we've covered.
the steps for performing SVD
we can then talk now. I know we didn't we didn't
do all of these like we did not get to we
haven't yet been able to look at an application and I
haven't yet talked about PCA. But if you understand SVD
I mean PC is just a simple small change.
Nsvd.
We can we can now start we can start with the applications
up so next week Monday rather.
We will start with tensorflow. So we will see neural networks.
And you will use PCA for dimensionality reduction.
And with one example in finance.
So I have a book.
It's a very good book by the way.
Quantitative Finance or quantitative methods
in finance. You know, I've I've a
number of books in economics.
And they're surprisingly very good at explaining math.
mathematical Concepts intuitively differential calculus linear
algebra
I found their explanation not just this
book. This is one of them, but just
I think it cannotics books to a very good job of explaining
math concepts like in very simple.
In very simple ways.
but I think it also helps that they give you examples and economics so
Whenever you put Theory and up.
Or theory and practice together.
It just makes the learning experience a lot better.
But yeah, I'm going to give an actual example application of
Finance from this book using PCA now that we've covered records.
Image compression if you remember this picture I showed you.
image compression with SVD
We'll go over the code for this.
It will take SVD on what we will take what we've learned about
SVD today.
So we can see how we can do image compression.
So computer vision example find example
and
dimensional reduction
everybody
no questions, right? No quote. No one else any questions before
I had the
okay.
Very well then.
Thank you very much. I hope you look forward to Monday.
Because it's it's gonna be completely practical.
You will learn about tensorflow.
So it should be you hopefully will find it very useful
in in the real world.
But thank you everybody. Thank you. Enjoy the rest
of your weekend, and I will see you very soon for now. Take care. Bye.